hey youtubers it's Charlie and
supernatural just got its season 10
officially I know no one is surprised we
totally expected this but I thought I'd
be fun to talk about the things we'd
really like to see in some of the early
predictions we have for what's gonna
happen because the Olympics are next
week I'll probably do another
supernatural bonus video maybe like my
top 5 characters that we want to see
come back hint hint sheriff Jody also in
slightly related news there is a new
game of Thrones trailer coming this
Sunday because sometimes hell is just a
hungry dragon be sure to subscribe to
get my breakdown it's gonna be a lot of
fun so before we talk about season 10 we
kind of have to wrap up season 9 because
there's still a lot of unresolved plots
so everybody grab some pie and let's get
going first off there's the war for
heaven and hell let's start up top
though the real problem is reopening
heaven they still haven't explained what
Metatron did that's keeping them locked
out so we don't even fully understand
what the problem is yet that's basically
Castiel's arced this season solving that
problem and ostensibly becoming a wiser
more sexed-up God with a few extra city
miles on him I don't know that I'd
forgive the show if they didn't make him
whole again eventually so my first
prediction for season 10 is the Castiel
will be made whole he'll get his grace
back since the spell that closed heaven
had something to do with his grace
obviously restoring that grace would
have something to do with reopening
heaven next up jump down into the fire
Abaddon and Crowley those two need to
just get a room already it's really just
a question of which one of them will
rule hell it's like now that the angels
are on earth the demons don't even care
they just want that sweet sweet human
soul honey the twist that I think that's
coming this season is that Crowley will
also be restored because who is he if
not the other side of that Castiel coin
by season 10 prediction for Crowley is
that he'll be the King of Hell and
working with Sam Dean and Castiel to
defeat Abaddon but wait a minute hold
the pie isn't Dean supposed to kill
Abaddon this season with the mark and
the first blade short answer yes but
this season something is going to stop
him from being able to do it because
they could totally never get rid of
Alaina Huffman she is far too precious
here's where my season 10 predictions
get tied up between Sam Dean and Abaddon
because I have to kind of talk about
them all at the same time if you haven't
seen it yet I predicted that because
Sam's possession tattoo got burned off
Abaddon will end up possessing him
preventing Dean from killing Abaddon or
Sam Adhan or whatever you want to call
them remember that's why Cain could not
kill Abaddon because she possessed his
wife so my season 10 prediction for
Abaddon is that she will start out
season 10 still possessing Sam
the alternative is the Dena's finally
able to get over himself and let's and I
and if supernatural has taught us
anything the last 10 years it is the
Dean will always be Dean he is not going
to change at least not permanently my
season 10 prediction for Dean is that he
will still have the Mark of Cain trying
to get Abaddon out of Sam at this point
there are not a lot of places the story
could go without creating a big reason
to bring God back into the equation and
the whole idea of the show is that God
left so my other big season 10
prediction is is that we still will not
see God there's no reason to think that
the show will not get a season 11 but if
they did want to end the series there
are only a couple of ways they could do
it without getting really really silly
so here are my top five ways they could
do that in order from a least likely to
most likely number five they both die
and go to heaven finally at peace
possible but highly improbable number
four
Dean sacrifices himself and Sam is left
to live out the rest of his life as a
hunter remember there's always going to
be evil in the world so there will
always need to be hunters this is a
slightly more likely outcome number
three their dad returns in a deus ex
machina sacrifices himself again in
order to try and make amends for being a
terrible dad and giving them such shitty
lives also unlikely but a final cameo
from dad would be a nice bookend of the
series and they'd both be alive at the
end of the scenario number two Dean
finally grows up inside and lets Sam die
for real then tries to live out the rest
of his life trying to figure out how to
stop being hunter and settle down
slightly more likely but still not quite
the best option and finally my number
one potential endings of the series
neither one of them dies and things end
with them giving the business to another
demon this is that open-ended ending the
one that would give fans in the story a
place to continue like nothing had ever
happened even if the TV show does end so
they just keep going on having
adventures in the comics and the books
getting themselves into all kinds of
trouble with the help of Castille and
Crowley so let me know what is your
biggest prediction for Supernatural
season 10 and if the show ever did end
how do you think they would do that so
like I said next week doing my top five
characters we'd like to see in season 10
be sure to subscribe to get that
also big Game of Thrones trailer
breakdown coming on Sunday night after
Walking Dead so it's gonna be a big
weekend it'd be a lot of fun everybody
be sure to go out and celebrate the
season 10 announcement by having a nice
piece of pie right now
click here to learn all about arrow
season 3 also got renewed yay and click
here to get my last week's supernatural
video thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys this weekend high
fives